In the previous video,
we preprocessed our data,
and we're now ready to extract
the word frequencies to be
used in our prediction problem.
The tm package provides
a function called
DocumentTermMatrix that
generates a matrix where
the rows correspond to
documents, in our case tweets,
and the columns correspond
to words in those tweets.
The values in the
matrix are the number
of times that word
appears in each argument.
Let's go ahead and
generate this matrix
and call it "frequencies."
So we'll use the
DocumentTermMatrix function
calls on our corpus that we
created in the previous video.
Let's take a look at our
matrix by typing frequencies.
We can see that
there are 3,289 terms
or words in our matrix
and 1,181 documents
or tweets after preprocessing.
Let's see what this
matrix looks like using
the inspect function.
So type
inspect(frequencies[1000:1005, 505:515]).
In this range we see that
the word "cheer" appears
in the tweet 1005,
but "cheap" doesn't
appear in any of these tweets.
This data is what
we call sparse.
This means that there are
many zeros in our matrix.
We can look at what the
most popular terms are,
or words, with the
function findFreqTerms.
We want to call this on
our matrix frequencies,
and then we want to give
an argument lowFreq, which
is equal to the
minimum number of times
a term must appear
to be displayed.
Let's type 20.
We see here 56 different words.
So out of the 3,289
words in our matrix,
only 56 words appear at
least 20 times in our tweets.
This means that we probably
have a lot of terms
that will be pretty useless
for our prediction model.
The number of terms is an
issue for two main reasons.
One is computational.
More terms means more
independent variables,
which usually means it takes
longer to build our models.
The other is in building
models, as we mentioned
before, the ratio of independent
variables to observations
will affect how good the
model will generalize.
So let's remove some terms
that don't appear very often.
We'll call the output
sparse, and we'll use
the
removeSparseTerms(frequencies,
0.98).
The sparsity threshold
works as follows.
If we say 0.98, this
means to only keep
terms that appear in 2%
or more of the tweets.
If we say 0.99, that
means to only keep
terms that appear in 1%
or more of the tweets.
If we say 0.995, that
means to only keep
terms that appear in 0.5%
or more of the tweets,
about six or more tweets.
We'll go ahead and use
this sparsity threshold.
If you type sparse, you
can see that there's
only 309 terms in
our sparse matrix.
This is only about 9% of
the previous count of 3,289.
Now let's convert the sparse
matrix into a data frame
that we'll be able to use
for our predictive models.
We'll call it tweetsSparse and
use the as.data.frame function
called on the as.matrix function
called on our matrixsparse.
This convert sparse to a data
frame called tweetsSparse.
Since R struggles with variable
names that start with a number,
and we probably have some words
here that start with a number,
let's run the make names
function to make sure
all of our words are
appropriate variable names.
To do this type COLnames and
then in parentheses the name
of our data frame,
tweetsSparse equals make.names,
and then in parentheses
again colnames(tweetsSparse =
make.names(colnames(tweetsSparse)).
This will just convert
our variable names
to make sure they're
all appropriate names
before we build our
predictive models.
You should do this
each time you've
built a data frame
using text analytics.
Now let's add our dependent
variable to this data set.
We'll call it
tweetsSparse$Negative =
tweets$Negative.
Lastly, let's split our
data into a training set
and a testing set, putting 70%
of the data in the training
set.
First we'll have to load the
library catools so that we
can use the sample
split function.
Then let's set the seed to
123 and create our split using
sample.split where a
dependent variable is
tweetsSparse$Negative.
And then our split
ratio will be 0.7.
We'll put 70% of the
data in the training set.
Then let's just use subset to
create a treating set called
trainSparse, which will take
a subset of the whole data set
tweetsSparse, but always take
the observations for which
split==TRUE.
And we'll create our
test set, testSparse,
again using subset to take the
observations of tweetsSparse,
but this time for
which split==FALSE.
Our data is now ready, and we
can build our predictive model.
In the next video, we'll use
CART and logistic regression
to predict negative sentiment.